hey guys I'm Rami Yousef and today I'm
going undercover on the Internet it's
actually me the winner is Rami the best
show about New Jersey since a brand
house I don't know it could be I mean
New Jersey always looks so bad I say
this all the time but trying to defend
Jersey's way harder than trying to
defend Muslims like people have their
prejudices I think we're the mob they
think the whole thing is the shore so in
terms of positive jersey representation
yeah I think we're up there how to watch
in a whoo this country I don't think I
can legally say but people find a way to
watch the show it's also available
actually on a lot of places that have
picked up the show so depending on where
you are it's probably somewhere we've
distributed it which is which is excited
you can read Arabic I'm so proud for you
something great Egyptian man nominates
for the Golden Globe good luck Rami
thumbs up thank you so much that's
really that's basically I do read Arabic
orally I will admit but I can get
through it I speak Arabic but the the
reading is probably a little fourth
grade level yeah right around there the
basics who plays your parents isn't the
father movie and Egyptian actor yes
I'm Rebecca plays my dad Egyptian Legend
and it's amazing to have that dude on
the show
Rami how has your acting training
influenced your writing and how has
writing influenced your acting that's a
really good question I think I found in
acting training when you can't remember
the lines usually means it's bad writing
and so it kind of started to feed off
each other I'm like okay if I can't
remember my lines that means I probably
wrote them wrong and then when you're
writing you really want to kind of like
act it out so most of my writing is just
be walking around in a room talking to
myself like a crazy person because it is
legitimately crazy endeavor for crazy
people and if you think anything
on-screen seems crazy because it is
because this is it's all insane and fake
but real is a picture of me and my
sister and then someone says I'm a brew
cromby well deserved
have you tried letting her hold the
award so she can feel its power and
awesomeness but don't stand too close
she might hit you with it hashtag
sisters
that's very true I like the username - a
crafty Arab no I did I let my sister
hold it I was actually trying to get her
to hold it for me while we were walking
it's heavier than you think it is it's
super heavy my arm was getting so I was
like can you hold this she's like sure
how's it for a second and then yes she
was gonna hit me with it if I didn't
take it back that's all right I held it
for the rest of the night Wikipedia he
was raised in Rutherford New Jersey
attended Rutherford high school
performed sketch comedy while studying
political science and econ in college
yeah while there Youssef serves as a
camp counselor her youth leadership
board in New Jersey I can't believe that
me being a camp counselors on my
Wikipedia page
somebody's gotta edit this I don't know
how this happened obviously someone from
the camp edited the Wikipedia page I
didn't know that they had you know
privileges to do that in a camp
counselor was amazing I used to do this
thing where we would it was in the woods
and no one was allowed to have their
phones and so we do this thing to the
kids work we'd order a box of pizza we'd
order like five boxes of pizza and then
we'd pull out every one at night and be
like who ordered this pizza like one of
you did it and then we try to see who
would tell on someone and then if
everyone stood there God would be like
you guys you guys made the count but
some years some people would just
straight up be like dude it was max and
then max gets in trouble but he doesn't
you know the kid who usually did in it
on we would celebrate them burger taking
the fall so it was really all about
leadership
Instagram hey Romney what are you
reading I think I was a book of poetry I
don't remember what the poems were
though is more of a vibe you know I kind
of like bought the book read a couple
pages I it's hard to finish a book
especially a poet I don't think I
actually don't think poetry books are
meant to be finished like I think you're
supposed to just kind of open it up get
a little and then I would argue most
books or not maybe finish I think you
just kind of get a couple you get the
idea and you carry it with you and then
it becomes you know part of your life
subconsciously this fix your music is
though says is it taken in Egypt or in
the States
this is actually taken in the States but
we made it look like Egypt because
that's what happens when immigrants come
here and we just make our entire house
look like where we came from so that it
feels like you didn't leave and then
you're like well why did you leave and
and that's the it's the question we
never find an answer to any comedy shows
in New York anytime soon all the time
always popping up doing stand-up a lot
of the show is based on stand-up so I'm
trying to keep it going keep it fresh so
yeah I do that post about it sometime
but then there's also a comment here
that says oh so cute I can't even take
it to which you know just don't just
just unfollow YouTube is Isis or
breakfast a reference to coffee or
suicide Wow
no but that's I didn't realize that I
was Lhasa fising on that level cool
wait he's suppose he in New York New
Jersey what's up with his accent no
shade I'm from California but this dude
sounds like he's from Morehead yeah it's
really funny cuz when people when I was
growing up in Jersey they just called me
Cali which I don't know what like accent
wise I'm just happy I don't have a
Jersey accent but I actually learned
Arabic first and then learned English I
think somewhere there you know the
accent formed but I'll take Orange
County over South Jersey
the teachers dawa while doing stand-up
doc Dawa means you know spreading the
faith and I don't know maybe how chill
is this dude what happens when he gets
high I don't know I haven't gotten I I
have no idea what would happen I think
if I started I wouldn't stop which is
why I haven't done it but weed looks
cool smoking looks cool and I I feel
like I would want to do it I would never
get anything done so I haven't done it
yet my plan is to do it when I'm like 50
like I want to kind of get a bunch of
stuff done maybe you have kids get them
to a certain age and then just be like
dad's in the basement he's a dad's
always in the basement why I
[Music]
height 5 foot 9 I feel like this was put
in here to questioned and challenged if
that's actually my height would choose
with shoes so I think if you put the
shoes on it's 5 9 read it he's ending
Ramadan in a bar odd but ok yeah 1 1
Ramadan I did I did stand up in a bar so
I wasn't going to I was going to work
that's part of the Arab Muslim work
ethic which is even if it's Ramadan I'm
working and doing my job
the stand up brought me to the bar what
can I say you know I was there around
Hilux overall do they do any more does
that mean he's not bringing back the
Hulu show for another season
no the Hulu show is coming back our
second season comes out May 29 and
hopefully we'll do many more maybe two
more I don't want not many it'll get
people get tired of me
[Music]
does the TV show Romney accurately
depict an Egyptian American family a few
of them yeah I mean I think it
definitely hits a lot of it and a lot of
things some Egyptian American families
don't go through yeah thank you for your
questions and that's it I'm signing off
[Music]